the MBC it's the voice and the battle
rounds beginning one of the folks we
just can't wait to see is Paymar Davis
who gets her turn on Tuesday now you may
remember the Tamar has spent her entire
career this close to superstardom she
worked with Prince and was an early
member of the group that eventually
became Destiny's Child so that's Beyonce
back in 1993 look behind her there's
Tamar her parents pulled her out of the
group
so she could go to school meanwhile the
band girls time was renamed Destiny's
Child Oh what could have been what was
it like watching those girls as they go
along their journey and you're sitting
in school and you're like oh yeah I
remember just crying at night they just
became huge so it was very hard for me
you know it's funny I had not spoken to
the girls since we were 10 years old 13
years later Tamar and Beyonce reunited
Beyonce was in a role in front of me and
we ended up hugging each other and it
was just like are we really grown women
hugging each other at the Grammys I'll
never forget that moment she's now an
early standout on the voice but Tamar
story is really a lesson in how everyone
has their own path to success right now
Patti LaBelle is her advisor but before
that Prince considered Tamar his muse
look there she is in 2006 et cameras
caught her singing backup but another
star in her corner Tyler Perry he's
actually the whole reason she's fair he
kept saying what are you doing with your
music how are you gonna pursue it you
should do the voice and I kept saying no
no no no and that final time I said okay
mr. Perry I'll try it okay got to ask
you as the voice said let's reach out to
maybe Prince maybe Beyonce
Kelly Rowland or Michelle I don't know
that will be very interesting I would
love to do a Beyonce song and is there a
print song you would want to do if
prints would clear Purple Rain and just
somehow just come up out of the floor
and play yeah purple ink
definitely hands down